that's the difference between a liberal
and an illiberal order because if you're
living in a country that has big
religious divisions in it if you pick a
single one of those Division I mean even
you know even in the case of
protestantism there's so many sects
within protestantism that you're still
not going to get National Unity you know
just within that one you know branch of
Christianity and that's why religion has
always been very problematic that's why
you know what Modi is trying to
accomplish in India right now is
extremely problematic because there's
200 million Muslims living in India that
aren't part of his understanding of what
it means to be an Indian and in fact
he's disenfranchising a lot of them